Now, of course, this is a little bit subjective, but to me, it's clear that
showing that SAT is NP-complete was the hardest thing that we had to do
because we didn't know any other problem to be NP-complete,
so we had to go through a lot of effort to show that
any problem in NP can be expressed as a boolean formula for SAT.
Then I think that showing clique to be NP-complete was the next difficult thing
because it's not really obvious how you can reduce SAT to clique
because SAT is a problem on boolean formulas; clique is a problem on graphs.
And so we had to find a good idea to show how SAT can be reduced to clique.
And then, in the first unit, it still took some thought, but showing how
vertex cover, clique, and independent set are related wasn't that difficult
because all three problems were asking questions about graphs,
and they were asking mostly very similar questions,
especially clique and independent set.
Vertex cover--yeah, we had to give it a little thought, but I still think it was much easier
than coming up with the idea of how to encode a boolean formula
into a graph that is then an input for clique.
So the good news is the hardest part is over,
but, of course, as you've seen with SAT and clique,
showing NP-completeness can still be tough.
And that is why I would like to show you one more example of a reduction
for a quite-famous NP-complete problem that you don't know yet
and then give you some more general strategies
on how you can show NP-completeness for other problems.
And to introduce that problem to you, I would like you to meet Dave.